[Musique]
j'ai la chance d'être au kilomètre 60
c'est un site qui est installé depuis
maintenant plus d'un an pour protéger le
territoire du Québec contre les coupes
abusives qui ont été faites par les
forestières c'est au cours des dernières
années et malheureusement ça a été une
réalité pour les communautés je pense
particulièrement par exemple au km 95 là
où vous venez remplia traditionnelle qui
était tenue par une famille protégée par
une famille justement a été complètement
rasé par de l'activité justement
foresterie pourquoi est-ce que je veux
en parler c'est que c'est une réalité
qui va exister de plus en plus en
différents endroits à travers les trois
grandes communautés à tika mec sur
l'intestinale puisque malgré le fait que
les communautés le gouvernement et la
foresterie ont souvent des discussions
entre elles souvent les ententes parties
qui se font ne sont pas respectées par
un détour des trois parties je peux vous
dire tout de suite c'est qui c'est pas
les addic donc cette réalité là force la
communauté
de voir s'installer sur des sites qui
sont habituellement les sites
tranquilles parce que on protège le
territoire sans avoir besoin de
l'appliquer mais maintenant en utilisant
un des droits ancestraux de pratique sur
le territoire un des droits aussi qui
est reconnu par la Constitution c'est à
dire d'être autochtone sur son propre
territoire dans le fond en utilisant les
corps autochtones on peut encore
protéger le territoire et là je pense
beaucoup aux étiquettes parce que
présentement je suis dans le territoire
anti-québec mais on voit cette réalité
là aussi exister présentement chez les
watts souhaitons justement il y a eu des
arrestations protecteur du territoire on
voit qu'il y a des injonctions qui sont
envoyées à d'autres protecteurs du camp
ici au Québec c'est une réalité
malheureusement qui est malgré le fait
qu'on dit qu'on a des ententes que
justement les communautés acceptent une
certaine partie de coupe forest Ière
la machine est gourmande est souvent
elle ne s'arrête pas tant qu'on mettra
pas un pied devant justement
si ces couples alors ce qui est
intéressant avec le kilomètre 60 et
c'est une collaboration entre le
gouvernement du conseil de manowan et
aussi des membres de la communauté qui
sont là et qui pour manifester le refus
des confort et ça ne font qu'uniquement
exister sur leur propre territoire donc
pourquoi j'en parle vous savez que j'ai
cet intérêt là mais c'est pour parler
aussi de cette réalité qu'être
autochtone au Canada en 2023 ça veut
dire souvent d'être uniquement toujours
à devoir défendre quelque chose avec son
corps et ça tombe en plein moment où
même l'église elle-même reconnaît que le
terrain nulus c'est-à-dire la doctrine
de la découverte est une doctrine sur
laquelle on n'aurait jamais dû baser
l'exploration de l'Amérique du Nord et
maintenant on voit les conséquences et
aujourd'hui malgré que le terrain Ulis a
été
répudié on envoie les effets encore pour
les communautés donc c'est intéressant
j'invite les gens à suivre justement ce
qui se passe sur différents territoires
sur différentes dans différentes
communautés parce que c'est des enjeux
qui concernent justement les Québécois
les Canadiens autant que leur
gouvernement que les compagnies lesquels
pour lesquelles elles travaillent
et je pense que un des messages que les
communautés essayent d'envoyer de façon
désespérée c'est on peut exister dans
les territoires on peut prendre des
ressources du territoire en tant
qu'humain c'est une réalité qui la nôtre
cependant le mot responsabilité et aussi
important donc de pouvoir profiter du
territoire de pouvoir en
vivre en jouant c'est important mais il
faut ne jamais oublier responsabilité et
c'est malheureusement ce qu'on voit que
l'industrie n'a pas se prendre la
responsabilité des septures générations
et de s'assurer que la ressource ne
disparaîtra pas c'est pas les seules
problématiques forestières les
changements climatiques aussi
présentement on en discute avec
plusieurs années et il voit un
changement qui est quand même assez
drastique sur leur capacité à exister et
pas uniquement humaine mais la capacité
aussi de la biodiversité qui est dans le
territoire de pouvoir exister dans une
intestinale
génération que l'humain va de laisser
son emploi alors je vous souhaite une
belle semaine je vais aller me
réchauffer parce qu'il fait froid je
vais aller continuer de profiter de ce
merveilleux territoire tant qu'il est là
parce que grâce aux étiquette je peux
encore m'y promener je vous souhaite une
belle semaine